Here's a mystery -- who exactly wants to see
another Sherlock Holmes movie? More than ten years
after the last one, we're about to find out
-- and the answer probably won't be pretty.
"I agree it's not my best
disguise, but I had to make do."
Ben Affleck may be a movie star, but the days of
an actor being able to put butts in seats on the
basis of their celebrity alone are pretty
much over… even for the star of "Gigli."
Knowing this, Disney's release strategy for "Deep
Water," a film produced under
its 20th Century Studios brand,
seems to be "release the movie quietly in
January, and whatever happens, happens."
In the film, Affleck plays a
wealthy husband hoping to stay
far away from a pricey divorce by letting his
wife, played by Ana de Armas, have extramarital
affairs -- but he becomes suspect number one
when one of her paramours suddenly vanishes.
The movie comes out on January 14,
and as of the making of this video,
there's not a trailer, or even poster for it yet.
With zero hype for the movie so far, "Deep
Water" seems to be in deep… well, you know.
Betting against Marvel is like betting against
the Harlem Globetrotters. But just because Marvel
boasts Earth's Mightiest Heroes, that doesn't mean
the brand is invincible — especially when it's not
Marvel Studios, but Sony's Marvel-affiliated
Spider-Man spinoff series. Confused?
"The Multiverse!"
It's hard to tell where Sony's
"Morbius" falls in the canon. We
think it's a spinoff of Tom
Hardy's "Venom" series, with
nothing to do with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe -- but these days, who can tell?
"I… am… Venom."
What we do know is that thanks to lots of delays
and bad buzz, the anticipation for this movie is
colder than its January release date, where
Sony is sending it to die a quiet undeath.
You may be saying, "So what? People said the
same thing about 'Venom.'" But Venom was one
of the 90s' most popular comic book villains,
and Morbius has always been D-list or lower.
It's possible that "Morbius"
will surprise everyone,
but it definitely won't be a big shocker if
this vampire monster mash mostly just sucks.
Video game movies are on an upswing,
based on the recent successes of "Pokemon:
Detective Pikachu," "Sonic the
Hedgehog," and "Mortal Kombat."
Is this a sign of a reversing trend
for video game movies, one of the
most critically maligned and commercially
spurious of all movie genres? Maybe -- but
we're not betting on it, especially not for
the first big-screen-outing of Nathan Drake.
Yes, he's the main protagonist of
"Uncharted," one of the best-selling,
most critically acclaimed video game series
ever -- but the key phrase here is "video game."
Gamers like playing games as Nathan Drake,
they don't necessarily like buying a ticket to
watch Tom Holland play a young Nathan Drake.
While Tom Holland may be a draw as
Spider-Man, everybody is a draw as Spider-Man.
Outside the MCU, Holland hasn't shown
his mettle, and playing a square-jawed
adventurer seems like a stretch for the
charmingly befuddled young Brit. Still,
we're always up for an old-school adventure. We'll
just probably be the only people in the theater.
Marvel Studios could probably release a
movie about Doop and it would still gross
a billion dollars. Meanwhile, DC's
cinematic output has been a little more
hit or miss. Joker grossed a billion
dollars; Birds of Prey, not so much.
Now DC is taking a swing with "DC League of
Super-Pets," scheduled for summer 2022. In
the animated film, Superman goes on vacation, so
protecting the planet is left to his dog Krypto,
Ace the bat hound, and a league of super pets.
Krypto and Ace are voiced by
Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart,
stars of the rebooted "Jumanji" series.
They're joined by a stacked voice cast,
including Keanu Reeves, Kate
McKinnon, and John Krasinski.
"The LEGO Batman Movie" showed you can make
a popular, family-friendly comedy spoofing DC
characters. Still, this feels like a charming HBO
Max series, not a blockbuster movie families will
shell out money for, at least enough to justify
what we're sure is a budget pushing $100 million.
If it's good, it may make money. If it's so-so, it
may end up being more of a wait-and-stream thing.
If it's bad, well… it wouldn't be the first
DC property to arrive to harsh criticism.
"I am not someone who is loved.”
Roland Emmerich's schtick of "humans vs.
world-ending disaster" used to be a pretty
reliable formula, financially. But for more than
a decade, the biggest disasters in Emmerich's
filmography haven't been on the screen but at
the box office. He hasn't had a hit since 2009's
"2012," which predicted the end of the world but
actually foretold the end of his impressive run.
In between ,there have been a few
misbegotten attempts at small-scale films,
like "Anonymous" and "Stonewall", peppered
with massive bombs like "Independence Day:
Resurgence" and "Midway." In our prediction, look
for "Moonfall" to continue the downward trend.
"You know, we are just inside the moon." "
That might be the greatest
sentence anyone's ever said."
As the title suggests, "Moonfall" is about
the moon getting knocked out of its orbit
and going on a collision course with Earth.
It stars Halle Berry and Patrick Wilson,
talented value-adds in "John Wick" and "Aquaman"
movies but not reliable draws on their own.
So with an eye-rolling concept and unreliable box
office draws, "Moonfall" has a massive mountain
to climb to earn a profit on its reported $150
million budget. Maybe China will save the day,
but domestically, the only audience for "Moonfall"
are dudes aged 18-to-34 who are watching it
ironically. A prime demo, to be sure, but not
enough to save "Moonfall" from crashing to Earth.
Nearly 20 years after its original release,
"Shrek 2" remains one of the 15 biggest
animated worldwide hits ever and one of
the top five of all time domestically.
A big reason why was Antonio Banderas' turn as
the swashbuckling Spaniard cat, Puss in Boots.
The character was so popular that he even inspired
his own spinoff, which was a big hit in 2011,
grossing $149 million domestically and $554
million worldwide on a $130 million budget.
However, 11 years will have elapsed since
the original "Puss in Boots," and the magic
number between sequels is between two and four
years. Any shorter and you risk oversaturation.
Any longer and you risk the audience moving on.
The latter is particularly a risk with animated
movies, as the original audience has literally
grown up. Disney and Pixar can get away with it,
but we don't think "Puss in Boots" has that
sort of staying power. We're predicting the
box office for "Puss in Boots: The Last Wish"
will stink worse than week-old kitty litter.
One of the biggest casualties of the COVID-19
pandemic's effect on the film industry may be
"Top Gun: Maverick," which is now set to arrive
36 years after the release of the original movie.
Originally slated for release
in the holiday season of 2020,
it's now set to take off,
finally, in September 2022.
As far as release date shuffling goes,
"Top Gun: Maverick" has been moved around
so much we feel like we're sitting in the
back of a F-16 fighter jet hitting Mach 2.
Is that disadvantage made up by the combo
of Tom Cruise and nostalgia? We doubt it.
Cruise's four-decade movie star run is nearly
unprecedented in its level of success, but lately,
he's only been reliable in the "Mission:
Impossible" movies. Maverick is one of his most
iconic characters, but "Top Gun" is memorable in
a "it was on TBS in the afternoons" kind of way,
not in a "my family watched
it every year" kind of way.
There's a difference between genuine nostalgia,
a la "Jurassic World," and a sequel to a popular
movie from a bygone era, like "Independence
Day: Resurgence". Decades later, the world
doesn't feel like it was begging for
a "Top Gun" sequel. In other words,
we just don't think modern moviegoers
still have the need... the need for speed.
Elle Woods first sashayed her way onto Harvard
Law's campus for 2001's "Legally Blonde."
Fresh-faced Reese Witherspoon proved her
box office bona fides with the movie,
powering the $18 million film to
a $141 million worldwide haul.
You don't need a high-priced law degree to know
profit margins like that are mighty impressive.
Two years later, "Legally Blonde 2: Red, White,
& Blonde" brought Elle Woods to Washington, D.C.,
and put $90 million domestically and $125 million
into studio MGM's pocket. On a $25 million budget,
"Legally Blonde 2" was slightly less successful,
and that was the end of the story… until now.
MGM famously had monetary woes throughout the
2000s, which probably contributed to putting
off a timely three-peat. In the meantime, the
"Legally Blonde" brand expanded beyond the
multiplex to Broadway. So, nearly 20 years
later, does the moviegoing audience still
care about "Legally Blonde," a franchise
very much of its time? We don't think so.
While the plot is unknown, Elle Woods'
saga succeeded because it was the ultimate
underdog story -- and we're not
just talking about her chihuahua.
We imagine this movie will rely more on
nostalgia than on inspiring new audiences,
and in today's movie landscape,
that just won't be enough.
"What?" "Elle."
Have we passed peak Sherlock Holmes? Maybe.
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's world-famous sleuth
first appeared in "A Study in Scarlet" in 1887,
and the character has remained a
figure in pop culture ever since.
BBC's modern-day "Sherlock" series brought
Benedict Cumberbatch's "high-functioning
sociopath" Holmes to the small screen, and
Warner Brothers' "Sherlock Holmes" films,
which turned Robert Downey
Jr.'s Holmes and Jude Law's
John Watson into Victorian-era
action heroes on the big screen.
Both 2009's "Sherlock Holmes" and 2011's "Sherlock
Holmes: A Game of Shadows" made a pretty penny,
earning $1 billion worldwide on a
combined budget of $215 million.
We imagine Warner Brothers was begging for more
sequels, but "The Avengers" broke records in 2012,
and Downey went off to make another million
Marvel movies... you know… give or take.
So here we are, more than a decade later. Does
anyone still care about Sherlock Holmes? The
answer is elementary — no. We already know
that this particular incarnation of "Sherlock
Holmes" doesn't have the staying power of an
all-time great franchise like "Star Wars" or
"Toy Story." When was the last
time you even thought about it?
Our prediction: This'll fall harder
than Sherlock off Reichenbach Falls.
This may be the Pandora of all hot takes.
After all, "Avatar" is the highest-grossing
movie of all time, with $2.8 billion worldwide.
Based on pure math alone, even if "Avatar 2"
dropped 50%, it would still be one of the
highest-grossing movies ever with $1.4 billion.
Even if it dropped 75%, it'd still be
flirting with $1 billion worldwide.
"This is why we're here."
"That's the only reason. It's
what pays for the whole party."
Given China was still a small market
when the first film was released in 2009,
and a re-release in China is the main reason
"Avatar" reclaimed its title from "Avengers:
Endgame" in 2020, are we crazy for including
it on our list of movies that will bomb? Maybe.
Yet unlike "Star Wars," "Lord of the Rings," or
"The Matrix," "Avatar" didn't have staying power.
Sure, everybody saw it in 2009 ... but only
because we had to. How many kids dress up as Na'vi
for Halloween? Where are the "Avatar" cartoons,
video games, and toys? Put simply, who cares?
At this point, "Avatar 2" has been pushed back
six times, will come out 13 years after the first,
and reportedly costs $250 million. "Avatar 2"
may make money, but it's hard to see how its
box office could be anything but a pale imitation
of its predecessor, and depending on how people
react to it, it may pave the way for three more
box office disasters in the series' future.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.